hey I want to talk about what's
happening in Colorado with the prices of
marijuana the cost of a wholesale pound
of marijuana in October in Colorado was
around $2,500 per pound that has been
almost cut in half to around $1,500 per
pound last month according to data from
an online marijuana distribution
platform which is as you can imagine
studying this very very seriously that
it is called I believe it's pronounced
trade if although it might be traded
saying in nearly a year we've seen
wholesale prices drop to nearly half of
their previous totals we've never seen
prices like this and this is because the
market is flooded right growers are
ramping up production there's a huge
amount hitting the market in Colorado
and this is causing the decline in
prices regardless of demand and as we
know Jason demand is very very strong in
Colorado right now for legal weed
similar story from Washington State
where the price of legal marijuana has
also dropped since significantly it's in
the sense the first dispensaries opened
so there this is sort of a double-edged
sword right on the one hand you are now
allowing people to do this legally and
that's a great thing you can tax it
revenues to Colorado have been huge you
can take that money and use it for drug
addiction education really thinking of
drug addiction as a health issue not a
criminal issue it's all absolutely
fantastic at the same time we are seeing
the price go down very very
significantly which we could argue is
bad for the growers but it is also good
in terms of eliminating the black market
because we've reported over the last
year that the black market for for pot
in Colorado still exists because due to
regulation the recreational legal
marijuana cost was still higher so you
get the black market and they say hey
we're not regulated we're not paying
taxes so we're going to be able to offer
a lower price this is good news in terms
of making the black market dealers
basically unnecessary or moot or
obsolete because the prices are dropping
very drastically
the legal side and I think it's gonna be
a great thing also in that whenever and
I say whenever because I feel like it
will happen yeah
the DEA actually gives a green light for
research to happen it's gonna cause the
the cost of the research to very cheap
and next thing you know they're gonna be
creating all of these compounds cdb
compounds and they're gonna destroy the
pharmaceutical industry CBD CBD
compounds yeah I agree with you I mean
right now there are so many obstacles to
research not that big pharmaceutical
companies can't go out and score some
pot they would be able to but big
picture yes if it's cheaper that is also
going to facilitate research although
the Schedule one disaster of merit of
cannabis is one of the problems the
difficult way in which research is even
possible is one of those problems so
there's a lot of different issues here
on balance I understand that this will
impact growers profit margins are still
very solid for growing marijuana
I think big picture this is actually
going to be a positive thing and you
have to remember that even if the prices
go down at the wholesale level when we
have more legalization and more markets
the opening of new markets is going to
do way more to help these businesses
remain profitable and many of them are
very very profitable I've been reading
about it I'm not finding myself hugely
concerned with the decrease it really
does make sense one you once you bring
something legal there is going to be you
know I'm not a total free market guy but
there is going to be a market force that
is going to decrease the price that's
just expected yeah and especially as so
I know something else going on in
Northern California similar to there is
companies like Marlboro have been going
to buy all these huge tracts of lands in
certain areas which are optimal for for
creating this right but what I hope is
there's gonna get so low in price that
it's gonna keep the curse certain kind
of a small growers in business and not
allow for these huge big business
wholesalers like marble etc to come in
and take over the market I think they
are going to come in and take over the
market if really we see legalization
we've already seen a variety of
different patents start to be filed
including even by the government in
terms of
medicinal uses I think that Big Pharma
and the tobacco companies both are
laying the groundwork so that if
legalization in terms of recreational
use becomes widespread they are
absolutely going to be there and
honestly I don't know that there's much
we can do to prevent it from happening
no there's nothing we can really do to
stop it I know they have been setting
the muscle cells up they have been
buying the land in these certain areas
like that the law is I know in
California if you buy a 10 plus acre
attractive land you can basically do
whatever you want there right and it's
hard to find these properties and I know
something from my friends that are kind
of initiative Sheree if you will I like
that a nice way to say so so what
they're doing though is in California
they've given kind of a a chance for
these people to catch up in this year
last year and next year do you try to
legalize themselves so when the when the
ballot measures do come up they actually
do have the money to apply for these
ridiculous kind of perma fees and that's
same thing with Massachusetts I think
the the cost right now is you have to
pay three rounds of fees to become a
medical marijuana dispensary in
Massachusetts 8050 and $3,000 in reverse
order actually and I thought it was more
to be honest I spoke to a lawyer who
worked with some clients who were
soliciting I believe he told me that the
entire process if if and up to including
the acceptance of it is half a million
and I don't know if he was including the
expected legal fees in that as well but
I've heard that these are just absurd
numbers well just the legal it just I
mean I'm excluding legal fees the actual
three fees you have to pay the permit
fees yeah are those but yeah I I have
heard as well that you need to have
basically a half a million upwards of
really a million dollars to start this
and the interesting part is it has to be
a non-profit business right so you have
to find a way to somehow circumvent all
of the the nonprofit kind of
restrictions that are there not to
mention most banks won't do business
with you because federally this is still
something that is illegal and in
addition to that you also have a
situation where you're handling major
major cash payments and you sometimes
need heavy security and you have a
non-profit which is hiring security in
this way not that nonprofits don't they
very often hire security no doubt about
that it's just a nightmare it's an
absolute and total nightmare I saw an
interesting advice interesting piece on
Vice about is actually and there's
actually a security they have a certain
security company that basically is the
backbone the kind of the pulse of this
industry and they go from every
dispensary and they have this huge vault
it's like its own it's like a private
bank essentially of all these
ex-military people that are running it
and it's kind of kind of very
interesting to see that is interesting
yeah and look at look at the industry
that's being created because so many of
these businesses have to deal with cash
okay that's the bonus show that's it for
today and we've we've got such a great
week of shows even though it is a short
week because of Labor Day it is quality
over quantity this week